Donald Trump blurted out yesterday
during a brief QA after another one of
these coronavirus propaganda events that
he has been taking hydroxychloroquine
for weeks now my immediate reaction I
don't know that he's telling the truth
and by the end of this story I imagine
many of you will share these doubts what
doctor would allow a president to take
something lacking any demonstrated
benefit with a high side effect risk
prophylactically particularly when
Donald Trump is a borderline or actually
obese which has negative interactions
with hydroxychloroquine it sounds weird
but here is Trump saying it the context
was attacking whistleblower Rick right
here's Trump claiming to be taking
hydroxi chloroquine as he always inserts
a sniff between the two words but you
people don't want to write the the news
you know but if you look but he's the
one that signed the application at the
very important forum he signed it now if
he doesn't believe in it why would he
sign it and a lot of good things have
come out about the hydroxi a lot of good
things have come out and you'd be
surprised at how many people are taken
and especially the frontline workers
before you catch it the frontline
workers many many are taking it I happen
to be taking it I happen to be taking it
contracted hydroxychloroquine right now
yeah a couple of weeks ago started
taking it because I think it's good have
heard a lot of good stories and if it's
not good I'll tell you right I'm not
going to get hurt by it it's been around
for 40 years for malaria for lupus for
other things I take it frontline workers
take it a lot of doctors take excuse me
a lot of doctors take it I take it now I
hope to not be able to take it soon
because you know I hope they come up
with some answer do we believe white
house doctors would let from go on a
medication because he heard a lot of
good stories
so either Trump is taking it and it's
crazy since it has large side effect
risks Trump is in his 70s with
cardiovascular health compromise or
Trump is lying about it and that's also
crazy either way this is crazy it's
either stupidity
or dishonesty now the back story is that
hydroxychloroquine among many others is
one possible treatment for coronavirus
that we looked at months ago I have no
idea logical opposition to it I listed
it for you on a list of about seven or
eight drugs before Donald Trump ever
mentioned it I think it's fine to look
into it so far the good randomly
controlled trials randomized control
trials don't show that it works now
here's another interesting thing when
you look into how hydroxychloroquine is
dosed for malaria which is what it's
approved for it's one dose per week so
you typically would start a week before
going to a country that has malaria risk
you take one dose then you take one dose
a week while you're there and then you
continue it for four weeks after you
leave the wacky ideas from people like
Sean Hannity and others is you take
chloroquine daily so question one is
this Trump claimed to be taking one dose
per week when he says I've been on it
for two weeks has Trump been taking it
daily for two weeks which would really
be wacky
so then Trump says the White House
doctor signed off on him taking this oh
I I think for whatever it's worth I take
it I was I I would have told you that
three four days ago but we never had a
chance because you never asked me the
question the White House did the White
House doctor recommend that you take
that is that why your White House doctor
didn't recommend no I asked him what do
you think you said well if you'd like it
I said yeah I'd like it I'd like to take
it a lot of people are taking a lot of
frontline workers are taking
hydroxychloroquine a lot of front door I
don't take it because hey people said oh
maybe he owns the company no I don't
know the company you know what I want
the people of this nation to feel good I
don't want them being sick and there's a
very good chance that this has an impact
so there he says well no the White House
doctor didn't come to me about it I
asked him and he said it's okay for you
to take it now here's Jeff Mason from
Reuters asking what's the evidence that
it actually works prophylactically and
listen to what Donald Trump says taking
it for about a week and a half now and
I'm still here I'm still can you explain
sir though you what is the evidence that
it has a prevented
here we go you ready here's my evidence
I get a lot of positive calls about it
the only negative I've heard was the
study where they gave it was at the VA
with you know people that aren't big
Trump fans gave it and we've done the
greatest job maybe of anything in the VA
he gets calls about it so that's his
evidence I like how he says the only
evidence that it doesn't work is that
thing from the VA that's the best
randomized controlled trial that we have
that's the one that has a large sample
size and Trump says other than that
which is by the way the best test we
have the best trial we have there's
evidence that it does work
prophylactically now shortly after Trump
said this chaos completely ensued and
the White House dr. Shawn Connelly put
out a memo about Trump and chloroquine
and a whole bunch of people said look
here's the letter here is the proof that
Trump is taking hydroxychloroquine look
at the letter
it doesn't say Trump is taking it it's
written in the most vague way possible
and it doesn't say Trump is on the drug
the letter that was published says two
weeks ago a trump staffer tested
positive for the virus the president is
in good health Trump and the doctor had
discussions about hydroxychloroquine and
they concluded the benefit outweighs the
relative risk I continue to monitor
studies the letter doesn't say we have
put Donald Trump on hydroxychloroquine
so I'm increasingly thinking this is
something Trump blurted out to get a
reaction and it's not even true although
we may never know FDA has a warning says
avoid the use of hydroxychloroquine
outside of a hospital or clinical trial
because of the potential increased risk
for serious heart related adverse events
and death so I don't actually care about
Trump having side effects at this point
listen if Trump is going to insist on
taking something and ignoring the
science he deserves whatever side
effects he gets as a result the problem
is that it puts others at risk it
encourages others to go and seek out
prescriptions for this medication it
puts Trump in extra danger if he's
telling the truth
sure and Trump by the way has
hypertension medication he takes
increases the side effect risk of
hydroxychloroquine but for me the real
signal that Trump is lying is that the
letter doesn't actually say he's taking
it and Trump says I've been on it for a
week and a half or two if you're
properly taking it which is one dose per
week Trump saying I've been on it on a
week and a half or two
have you gotten one dose or two one dose
or two unless Trump is actually taking
this daily which is absolutely bonkers
or it may all be a lie we may never know
we may never know but let's talk about
some of the reactions to Trump's claim
I'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep I sleep on
a helix mattress at home I absolutely
love it and that's why I reached out to
them about sponsoring the David Pakman
show buying a mattress in the past was
always a huge guessing game for me I
didn't know what I actually needed I
didn't know what I would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness I generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both GQ and Wired magazine it
is well deserved I can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty you can try the
mattress risk-free for 100 nights and
they will even come pick it up at your
house if you don't love it
but I know you will all of my viewers
will get up to $200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free when you go to the link right
underneath this video